dennis it's a pretty high rating
probably somebody whose name is dennis
dennis ed from spain
don't think i played dennis before
why am i playing one c5 i'm not thinking
is it because i'm gonna play my main
report war
probably it is i don't know other things
these days
knight c6 wow
you're not supposed to do that are you
yeah they don't they don't even teach
you about this grandmaster school
okay bishop c5 was just unbelievably
dumb
because he can just go knight a4 at some
point
so i'm admitting my mistake making a
shameful retreat
but i don't think if his plan is to go
if his plan is to go uh for
for your i for some point i don't think
that's a very good plan
i think you should play on the queen
side instead try to set up knight f4 and
and then it's not so easy to find a plan
here
okay
let me try something a bit radical
knight is going to d7 next trying to
prepare f5
queen h5 is obviously
a bit pointless seeing us i will be at
knight g7 with tempo
we couldn't see it first move it out of
the way and then
i feel like i'm ready for f5
whether it's a good plan i don't know
but it's the more i'm choosing
it's playing very quickly and very
confidently
what am i even doing
i don't know yeah this is this is them
it's really dumb
i really don't like the way i played
here
yeah i just weakened my position for no
reason
okay see fire i'm pretty happy to see
seeing as i get
defined by with temple
whether i should be is another question
but
for the moment i am happy to see it
playing so fast
okay try and grab a pawn while i still
can
didn't even realize that queen f1 was a
move
here but he didn't go for that so now
now i do feel like i'm getting
some sort of control over the position
rook f8 looks good
if he does go for rook effect
then bishop f8 and if queen f7 bishop g7
queen a7 i got d4 trying to push pawn
seems like i'm better and if jack then i
got king j8 and i don't think he has
anything clear take fish buffet but now
my queen on queen on e4 is ruling the
board
and whenever she tries to change it he's
probably gonna get
a losing ending so seems
very very promising for me now
yeah queen d1 but i'm not even going to
push d3 immediately just go
c5 first safeguard everything
seeing as d3 would have run into bishop
a7
i think their queen e2 was winning so
that wasn't necessary but
you can never be too safe
now i run into this instead huh
apparently i can be too safe
i'll go faster so let's take it
queen d5 we can go queen d a1
and continue the game but still
a5 um so now
it's just one push up c3 and then push
the pumps
king is not in time
a3 and then b3
whether or not you'll force me to flag
him
or to force him to meet him before he
flags
then i don't know
anyway yeah good game but
not happy with the way i'm playing right
now